so was that was that kind of eye-opening
for you to watch
to know what had actually happened and
then to watch the media cover it
like i i was already hearing about fake
news right yeah but when it happens to
you
it's like this feeling like a girl oh my
goodness you know and and then i loved
it because brian stetler comes on cnn
and it was like
let's talk about who this kim clay stick
is i'm like oh yes
yeah and i was like oh tell me about
myself you know and he's like you know
she wasn't even elected to the baltimore
county republican central committee
she lost i'd been on the committee at
that point for two years
i'm like dude you could literally just
go to the committee website
and see my name so he was just straight
wrong he was just putting up
oh my gosh everything he said was wrong
meanwhile at this point
you know i've been on fox news i've been
on one america you could see
any interview and hear them say klasik
he says kim clackic
they're like seriously i'm like so not
only are all the so-called facts wrong
you couldn't even pronounce my name so
how much how much research did you
really do on this
well you know i i was mispronouncing
kaylee mcandy's name for like a month
or longer and i just it never occurred
to me
but uh to be fair i just missed that one
that's my my bad
in terms of cnn i don't even think they
use google
i don't i don't think he actually looked
into who you were or what you were
talking about
yeah and and i gotta say you know i i
i take particular uh offense to the left
social justice narrative
because it's rules for thee but not for
me the idea that they could attack
candace owens is a white supremacist
but then you could take a white man a
wealthy white man like brian stelter and
he could just totally misrepresent you
no one bats an eye right now i don't
care about his race or yours if he's
going to criticize you i
think it's fine so long as he gets the
facts right right yeah but it flies in
the face of what their supposed
narrative
is really supposed to be about
absolutely and the fact that his show is
called reliable sources i know
i know right it kills me it's amazing
and
yeah and he wrote a book uh called it's
called
it's called like hoax i think and he
talks about the fox news trump
yeah yeah yeah it takes one yep yeah it
takes one another one
uh it's about like the fox news to trump
pipeline the craziest thing to me so
uh you know throwing it back to the the
first thing we're talking about trumping
this nobel peace prize
when when the news broke at first there
were like some tweets popping up where
they're like oh trump's gonna you know
he's being nominated is a huge deal
so i just i did a google search and i
try to read a bunch of different sources
the only source i found that had a
neutral presentation was fox
it was donald trump has been nominated
for nobel peace prize by you know this
guy he's a member of the norwegian
parliament who's a conservative blah
blah blah here's what he said
then they added in a little obama
criticism i'm not surprised
yeah all the other outlets were saying
he was like a far
right you know ultra nationalists like
it just it was
very very loaded and it wasn't telling
me about what the guy was saying about
trump or what his goal was it was trying
to insult the guy or or or poison the
well before we
had a chance to even understand what was
happening and that's the media today
yeah well outside of cnn though have you
have
any other run-ins with just fake news
putting up misinformation about you or
your campaign
absolutely um so i believe it's
msnbc yes tiffany cross
not too long ago i think um oh gosh
what's the young lady's name on the
on the view sunny austin yes
you know that i don't know it's a lady
they both said that um we were tokens
and that's why we were chosen to speak
at the rnc convention
and tiffany cross went to further and
said it was a minstrel show
wow i i had no idea i was pretending to
be black
black for 38 years but yeah no it's it's
insane
and um what's interesting about it is
i wasn't even chosen by the rnc to speak
it actually came from the trump campaign
the rnc
apparently wasn't too thrilled they were
like oh she had a campaign ad that's
cute
but i mean this is r z convention yeah
you were kind of last minute right
very last minute i i found out almost
like when everybody else found out
and so uh that came from the trump
campaign
so you know for her to say that the rnc
is throwing us in there
most of the black americans that spoke
at the rnc
were picks from trump you know this
wasn't like some rnc
push to say oh look we've got these
black people
but then this like you know damned if
you do damned if you don't right because
if we weren't there
then it's oh we're all the black people
yeah yeah
you know this is why it's it it really
is easy to criticize their fake ideology
this i think the democratic
establishment is using
the social justice progressive left and
pretending like they care
it gives them they've really crafted
this narrative so they can weaponize it
in either direction like you just said
but what's particularly offensive to me
in this regard is
the rnc was doing what they wanted what
they wanted right to prop up
marginalized voices to express
themselves
right and so they insult you directly
with a slur because they don't like
that you're speaking as a republican
yeah that's that's
that that's the go-to i guess it is but
you know
i i've i'm excited i go on the view
on september 18th oh
i'm going to talk to sonny myself do it
set her straight
and excited yeah are you going to well i
i'm
i won't go there i don't want to ask
about the racial components involved in
but uh here's what here's what i'm going
to do i want to jump over actually no i
want to show i want to show this first
right this is a story from the spectator
kim klasik and the urban gop effort
could a simple walk through the streets
of baltimore expand the republican party
now the the general idea that we're
seeing they mentioned that
you know you you launch this ad it goes
viral and
we had uh billy prempeon you know a
couple weeks ago
and he's he's he's brilliant he's a
really smart guy he's awesome
yeah and he made a really really
important point about the republican
party and what they need to do
he's in this district where it's i think
it's like d plus 13 or some or even more
than that it's like it's a democrat
yeah and so my question to him which is
i'll have a similar question for you is
it it feels like it's going to be a
really uphill battle i mean
for you you're in a d plus 26 district
right that's that's that so for those
aren't familiar that means it's like
26 percent more democrat or something to
that effect like it leans in that
direction
but what he said was no matter what
happens if i win i win if i lose i win
you know why
because he's there he's doing the work
he's talking to people and he's
spreading these ideas
right and so the crazy thing to me is we
kind of were approaching this a little
while ago
why isn't the gop doing anything you
mentioned
they said you can't win don't bother
right but how do they ever expect to win
if they've abandoned these areas
yeah no i that's a great question i
don't know and this is like
you know even in the special election i
would do hashtag chipping away
because you gotta chip away right before
you
you
know maybe i won't win but if you don't
chip away
you can't say it you've got a positive
mental attitude yes
i am going to win i'm going to win but
like he said
it's a win when you just at least chip
away and
expose what the other party isn't doing
you know when we did the whole when i
upload the videos about the trash
and i have to say at that point in time
in july 2019
there were i think it came down to close
to 70 000 backlog cases in the
sanitation department
the department of public works is what
picks up the trash in the city
they went to city hall city hall was
like why aren't we picking up the trash
in some of these areas
and they said well we need more funding
that's always it right they always need
more funding
um then you know after trump
calmed down he wasn't really talking
about baltimore anymore you know
congressman cohen passes away
basically i think it was not even five
months later
we find out that they've taken that uh
70 something thousand
backlog cases to 260. whoa
and they didn't get more funding so i
was like wait a minute
so you picked up the trash you didn't
get more funding
what happened is it because you got
called out on it
because people started looking into it
you know was someone investigating
and then you thought you know what maybe
we should go pick up the trash you know
this is the kind of stuff that happens
and it's again here's a situation where
you didn't have to throw even any more
money at it
yeah it's not even a question of uh the
congressional representative where's any
representative for these areas to get
the job done
did it really come down to your efforts
to finally start making people
you know you know what i'm gonna stop
right there and put it this way it's
it's like market competition for
politics
if the democrats have a super majority
it doesn't matter what their goals are
they don't have to do anything
because they know people are going to
check mark the d on the voter form right
as long as there's competition in any
capacity even if it's a name only
people actually have to start working
for the people they represent yeah
if that's that's why you said chipping
away and that's why i think billy was
saying if
he loses he wins because now there's
some competition
we're going to be coming for you and
we're going to go for it we're going to
try and make these changes
yeah well so i'll put it this way you
you you your ad specifically highlights
the trash uh i'm sure you're familiar
with scott pressler right
yes didn't he go to west baltimore and
he cleaned up
yes as soon as i posted those videos
they came out trump was talking about it
you know he he messages me and he's like
i'm gonna come there and pick it up
and i was like okay but what which
street
because all of them i don't know if
you've been here but there's a couple of
streets you probably
shouldn't do it on but i will help you
out so he came to town
um you know i was giving him some street
names of where i found the trash
a lot of it was by coppin university um
and he said okay we're gonna get our
team up there he mobilized all those
volunteers
it was amazing and then you know what
was crazy about it the local media the
baltimore sun then writes
how dare he come pick up the church
crazy
that that's that's why when uh
when we started this this this show they
want to end the nobel prize because
trump is nominated
it's the perfect formula of their
strategy so so scott pressler and a
bunch of volunteers and
and with you are able to actually make
this this this transformation which is
positive for everybody
and i saw the videos he posted those
aren't familiar it's actually that
simple
uh trump said what he said it was like a
rat infested
[ __ ] or something oh rat infested
rodent infested
did he yeah i think i think he's i think
he cussed at it he might have cursed
yeah
but but uh i think what happened was
they dragged trump for for it but
actually someone else had previously
said something similar they didn't care
about it i think it was jon stewart
actually
mm-hmm there was like a clip from the
daily show way back when where he said
baltimore was you know
just our own mayor walked through the
year previously and said
i can smell the dad the dead rats she's
walking through
with press here's what i love that
they wrote a hit piece about a dude who
got volunteers to clean up garbage
yeah and then all of a sudden we started
seeing this narrative that
they were just trying to make trump look
good or something and i started laughing
because i'm like oh no
you you got us you've tricked us by by
going out and cleaning up trash oh no
you've made trump look at
what what's what's what's the trick
there right
you cleaned up trash okay we're happy i
don't know i don't understand
that's insane to me no it is and if you
if people go back and look at scott
pressler's wardrobe
he wasn't even wearing anything that
said trump that's what another
i mean he wasn't advertising trump at
all yeah
that's what was so crazy about it he was
like him i really feel like
i just gotta come pick up the trash i
can't believe kids live there you know
and that's what all he was trying to do
and he's done it several times
oh yeah and whenever there's like
they always try to push the narrative
that his real goal isn't to help anybody
it's to make trump supporters look good
and help donald trump
and i'm like i don't i don't understand
how that makes
like how is that a smear against him
he's trying to make trump look good by
going around and cleaning up the
neighborhood and helping people
yeah is it bad that he's you know what
man look if if trump was an evil villain
and he was like you know i'm gonna win
over the hearts and minds of americans
by helping them get jobs and making the
economy better and getting them health
care
that's my evil plan to win it's like is
okay
helping people yeah that's the weirdest
weirdest thing to me
that's the best way to put it oh my gosh
but isn't that crazy though
no it is they literally wrote a hit
piece on that yeah i'm impressed i'm
impressed
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next
time